and then they like yo get on stage man
they start yelling this is a Stockton is
a pretty aggressive town and they just
like gallon now I start getting in
attack mode but I only have one come
back and I'm like your mother
[Laughter]
I won't even yelled at me they were like
start with the mother stop
[Music]
[Music]
go you ready for this yeah yeah you
ready for this this happened to this
yeah all right hot breath reverse
welcome back to the hot breath podcast I
am your host comedian Joel Byers this is
your weekly guide to comedy mastery and
today's guest is a master of originality
oh yes this cat started comedy almost 20
years ago after taking a speech class in
college little a little few years later
he actually makes his TV debut on a
little show called David Letterman where
he actually serendipitously booked by a
ring into the Booker in the lobby of a
hotel right here in Atlanta actually
since then he's been on shows like The
Office what he actually slept in his car
the night before that audition he's also
been on BET's Showtime Netflix
most recently he was one of the six
comics the Amazon was five or six did
they select I want to say eight but
they're only showing like five total so
maybe three bailed out so one of the
very select few to be having an Amazon
special right here in 2019 and now Wow
here's one of the very select few to be
on hot breath welcome to the show my man
I did it I made it the hot breath yeah
we made it you know out of the
distorting air what a pleasure thanks
for having me dude thank you for doing
this and I always like I like to reach
out to comics but I reached out to you
and you were like well hold on let me
check out the show yeah so what what
made you and a Mikey Winfield I don't
know if I even said your name that's
important for like he Winfield on hot
breath and that's that's great because
before you said that people were like
man do I know him from somewhere I think
I look like their black dude you might
know from somewhere so it's important to
throw the name out there so they can put
all that together a proper introduction
yeah that's great so let me tell you
what I have to make sure is I'm not on
nothing is just like repulsive or
disgusting on you know how like there's
certain people you go on road trips with
not all the time because they're the
funniest person because you can sit in
the car with them so if there's an inner
you where I'm like I can't even tolerate
this situation I'm not even gonna
consider it I feel so I watched other
stuff and I was like oh this is cool
this is great and I could see a good
vibe boom just like that yeah good vibes
here at hot breath and that's what I
loved in because I research all my
guests and I in researching you it's
this this self-made success you've had
specifically if we could jump into this
with your self-produced comedy special
we talked about your amazon special but
you actually first did your own comedy
special I'd love to dive into that
process yes man I mean it's good to have
a chip on your shoulder and feel slept
on to a degree boom you know I'm there
right now what I've always felt is like
I've auditioned for things and there's
things I thought I wanted but now my
theory for probably the last five years
has been just get in where you fit in
okay like don't chase at all just if
something is coming your way take that
that's what's meant for you so it was a
point where I wanted this and I wanted
that and I wanted all these other things
and it was like burning my energy and
negative ways so at that I was like man
I'm ready I like what I'm putting on
stage you know I'm grown as an artist
still so I decided you know put the
money up record my own special and I
mean it was a great experience it was
learning I shot it the way I wanted it
to you know like you see all these
specials and these big theaters and all
these things but at the time my thought
was I want to be somewhere where
everyone knows me you know where I'm
comfortable which was a club we threw
six cameras and a club you know I got
off camera six cameras we even had the
jig man it goes like and I'm so proud of
how it came out it was amazing I mean it
got great reviews you know it had a
limited reach because it self produced
so my whole goal was like try to sell it
try to sell it and we did and you know
man you know there we go again it's just
that thing where you put it out there
and no no one jumped on it and and
purchased it you know from like a
streaming company or network or anything
like that but the people
who saw that one when we were pitching
it to it it's who circled back and came
and approached me about shooting one of
these specials for Amazon Prime what
right right full circle like that so
that's man that's my inspiration in this
is like you'll just keep working and do
what you do and other stuff will just
come and fall into place and I'm a
living example of bad situation and when
we're let's let's let's get into the
weeds on this production so like when
you're cuz selfishly I'm I'm taping my
special that's what this is all about no
no no I know you sell produce until I
start researching you that is great and
it's always good to find a thread where
you're like oh yes because it's a lot of
comics that listen to this so I'm not
the only one who's like I want to do my
own special right so me selfishly I'm
filming in two weeks so this will
release after but like I don't want to
discourage you in any way either you
know but but with the conversation it's
gonna be pretty straight yeah good good
what do you got what do you go continue
with your questions and moving I'll just
I just I have a lot of thoughts
it's about recording your own special so
what are your thoughts that's my
question is what are your thoughts on
like a comedian self producing their own
special I think I mean times are
changing and you should put yourself out
there in the most quality way you can
impossible you know my my question is
like how long have you been doing
stand-up and what product are you
putting out are you going for an hour
are you going for an half hour are you
trying to pitch to networks do you want
to just upload it directly to you know
they got like video Amazon Prime direct
you could just push it on there and
drive sales do you already have the
following you know as so many tricky
things when it comes to deciding a
self-produced but I recommend everyone
do what fits for them and just continue
because we gotta we have to push
ourselves you know yeah and what
inspired me what one I've been doing
this almost 10 years okay
I'm planning to do like 45 minutes
but I'm I have like an alternate format
in terms of the structure of the actual
special that I don't want it to be just
me on stage for 45 minutes I feel like
there's an alternative way to kind of
approach the stand-up special format
especially now with so many flooding the
market I'm looking at I'm looking at a
little I'm looking at a left hook here
I'm coming in southpaw on the specials I
don't want to give away too much why
though can you say why be quiet don't
you want to do straight stand-up well I
can and I do yeah but I feel like every
like people are just seeing specials
over and over and over again and like
Netflix is flooded and it's just one
person talking for 45 minutes to an hour
but I'm starting to see people play
around with the format Julio Torres his
HBO special he was like playing with
shapes and a Gary Gulman eye I mean I
just saw this trailer like yesterday but
his seems to be more like it's going
into his backstory and also his dealings
with depression and there's like a theme
behind it so that I haven't seen that
special but that almost reinforced my
vision that maybe just standing on stage
isn't entertaining no no no there's a
way I'm gonna okay no no this is it when
a person is at that mental level where
you know what you do on stage you know
that an hour or 45 minutes which is a
great amount of time so Sam substantial
enough you know that it'll rock but I do
feel like if we're like let's figure out
another way to keep people interested
it's because maybe there's something
else going on that maybe a reason that
you don't want to or a person doesn't
just want to drop straight stand-up do
you feel like the attention spans are
different and we got a you got a trick
people I feel like the trend is heading
away from that oh and I just want to be
ahead of the the [ __ ] that's smart as
smart to be a
Irv's there's so much evolution and
stand-up and in County so I get that
part i'm just i do like many feel like
stand-up could be a stinked one day
could just it could just go away man
there's so much you know people trying
to pull you and make you lose stuff just
because of certain words you've said or
certain opinions you've had so I get it
but I'm I'm a purist like I'm stand-up
first like before anything I do for my
entire career like I'm stand-up first
and I'm not trying to do this as a
cop-out but I am trying to do this as
like I feel like it's starting the
pendulum is shifting over here so let me
just jump over here take a risk okay
and I know it's funny and like yours
being like step man and even researching
you you did an interview where the the
interviewer was talking about I like
your specials cuz I'm seeing like
different chapters of your life yes and
mine mine's gonna be called the trophy
husband so it's this is like chapter one
love it you know so yeah you in looking
at your body of work it's kinda like oh
yeah that's another way to do this game
where yours is like chapters of your
life as opposed to like here's here's a
stand-up special man here's another over
here yours is kind of unique yes it's
growing with me yeah and I feel like my
audience will continue to grow with me
and my style it's just one of those
things where I love regular life I love
everyday stuff and that's only what I'm
gonna discuss mmm you know so yeah
that's that's me right but making it
into material like you're known for your
writing and you were an English major
and yeah I'd love to dive into your
writing process - are you still daily
and what does that mean I love it
because one of the first mentions you
had was originality that's so that's so
important to me if not the most
important part of this other stuff like
the other things you know you can't
teach like fortunately I have like a
presence on stage you know and all that
it just came with it but the other
things anyone has access to if they put
it in time which is for me it is is
daily writing and I want this is what
I've slacked on lately I record but I
only listening to it now like twice a
week but but I've been making excuses
and that was a big excuse that's
terrible but man I did some colleges
over like the Kenda like last month and
what colleges I'm performing every night
then I'm flying the next day then I'm
driving for like two hours then you go
to the school and you do all this stuff
and then your flight leaves at 6:00 so
now you got to drop two hours to get to
the airport at 3:30 so you can be back
and there's no time to recoup so it's
just been about putting on a great show
versus growing is an artist which kind
of hurts mmm I don't like that feeling
is like I'm just doing this for the
check in a whole bunch of ways but since
the special dropped I'm telling you like
within that week I booked like 10 Club
weekends you know so like they're
reaching out they're hitting up my agent
and then BOOM things is like flatten out
the numbers are like this gradual growth
but this is what I love about the clubs
you get that you get that rhythm so now
I'm doing five or six shows in a weekend
yeah I get to stay here with coffee my
book and I just get to listen and I'm
listening every show I've listened to so
I'm back on the track that I want to
that's gonna get the best out of me as
an artist when when you're listening are
you taking notes do you have a set list
like okay so hey this is great
yeah I guess I guess I'm a share enough
of this process enough man it's like
there's certain things it's like I do
did I just only I'm gonna do write those
things but what I will say I just hear
myself talk so when I'm listening to the
recording I'm just like you should talk
about this so it's almost like the right
brain is like just talk about this now
and while I'm hearing myself talk it's
like I'm listening from like an
out-of-body experience telling myself
what to talk about and then I write it
down how I think it would be you know
funny I got my own Mikey Winfield
formula and then I just work it out and
I try it on a stage tonight or the next
night or the next night and I just keep
trying it and then I listed again in
this
like rinse and reuse you create setlist
before your shows I don't have to so
much of the setlist thing so what's
happening is I can visually see it I can
just see each area so what I have like
I'll open up and it'll just be like okay
let's start here and give them a
background let's kind of set the
foundation so that's kind of how my
special was I set the foundation of
being a merry due to her older woman
things that I'm interested in with a
stepson who's older that I call step man
boom that's set they're not going to you
know a step man story you're not kind of
dip into my relationship and that's like
my favorite thing to talk about so when
this podcast kicks off from I see my own
it's gonna be like relationship stuff or
people talking you know the inside what
they're willing to share so and I just
kind of see it in like visuals in
stories and that's how I write it all
down and then I just perform it you you
write like free writing like where you
just kind of do stream of consciousness
writing because I know you're big on pen
and paper which I yeah yeah definitely
and you like you value notebooks and you
like yeah like you're big on like my
favorite pin is the big Atlantis like
I'm I'm nerdy about the writing side all
the books - yeah yeah so like are you
free writing or is it more like lists or
no I like I just write stuff down then
I'll go back and read it and say like oh
is this still funny to me guys but this
is the problem with that sometimes I'll
talk myself out of trying something that
I thought was funny when I first wrote
it and then I'm like I don't know but
now when I just go up and try everything
sometimes I'm like okay that was funny
and I base it off their reaction and I'm
like okay just just trust yourself and
just go and do this so yeah it's
basically just writing stuff down and
trying everything every once in a while
I'll take notes on stage but that's so I
don't forget to try the new material
mm-hmm cuz when I don't try it I feel
like I just wasted a set mm-hmm and when
you're trying this new material like
even you like I consider listening as
part of writing like I find new
punchlines just in listening my set so
you were you were work
on a story about your experience in Las
Vegas yes so in building a story you
just kind of go on stage and tell the
story as is and then you listen back and
say like oh there's a funny idea I can
inject next time you kind of peel like
that but I think about what's funny
about it or what I consider funny about
it so I'm telling the story with you
know the in game has to be jokes and all
this they're happy comedy yes children
it has to be funny laughs this is my
pain of like comedy nowadays I feel like
so many people are stuck on I gotta give
this point of view or I got a had this
opinion and the the punchlines are not
living up to the strength of the opinion
so all I know is how you feel but I
haven't laughed you know that that hurts
I'm like develop and there's a lot of
potential and many to get funny but just
get funny you know that's why the people
are there if you just want to go to a
conference and hear someone's opinions
like go get some political rally or
something you know but at a comedy club
people I go to comedy clubs cuz I want
to laugh right be entertain man I don't
just want to learn something you don't
want a spoken word
yeah yeah and you had a breakthrough
when you stopped trying to be funny
yeah so early on that's what I was just
forcing it I was like and I got a lot
off with you know like looking funny
like just looking at entertainment right
so it's twisted cuz then some of the you
know charisma might sell jokes that
don't need to be sold
so yeah so I had to kind of dial back in
really detail what I'm saying and what
am I trying to say and what's the point
of this joke and then where's the the
twist ah so that's that's a good place
to start is like what am I trying to say
or even like what is the point of me
saying that that's a great thought and
your joke okay I hear you know jokes and
I don't think everyone is even listening
to what they're saying you like you know
what you're just setting that joke
always remember your material but they
will remember what your point was like
oh yeah that's the guy that was talking
about you know you know how dogs
shouldn't be neutered you know whatever
it is so I think it's important to know
what you're talking about
that's that's fascinating because I
recently came across that maybe in the
past year or so where I did start
getting more personal and then that's
when people start coming after the shows
telling me specific jokes they liked and
like oh that's just like right my wife
and our dog or that's just like my uncle
and they started to actually come up and
be able to tell me the jokes as opposed
to you were funny nice job right that
was a big shift for me just like a year
ago they're like that personal is when
people actually start I think that's
when you connect yeah that's really when
you connect with people is when they see
themselves or even a piece of themselves
in you and then they're like I like this
person right and you're able to which is
something I want to do more is like
translate these experiences into like a
story like you had this lady sat on your
lap yes and now it's this whole huge
story like yes you can remember it
seemingly on like on paper it would be
like so after a show this lace out of my
lap and it was crazy and then I couldn't
stand up all right how do you stretch a
a moment like that how do you stretch a
moment out like that I always thought I
mean that's what you do is tags you just
really okay and I see it all in pictures
so I can still see that lady doing that
okay and man it was people around she
was so comfortable and she was wide and
soft and she just said yeah you know
comfortably and she turns to me and I
remember my feelings like it felt good
but then I was like it's just wrong like
am i cheating on my wife right now
that's how I felt cuz I was enjoying
this lady's lap and she had a warm ass
and you know it was everything about it
was fun comfortable it was wrong it was
right it was perfect and that's what
happens after shows now so now women
come to you like [ __ ] or your laugh
they remember the jello they really
remember that's interesting you
remembered how you felt in that moment
and you make sure you bring that feeling
to the state absolutely and that's the
connection the feelings like it's not a
surface story it's internal while I was
in this situation why I felt that way
these are the parts of it that I think
are funny mm-hmm yeah and you you
brought in like your perspective her
perspective the guy taking the photo so
like when you're building a story it's
almost like you want to give like a 360
view of it yeah that's it I want this
picture from every single angle and then
I'll give it from just like angles you
don't expect yeah it'll be like the
camera man's feelings all right all
right I think that's what comedy is like
especially original comedy it's just
finding a route that everyone else may
not go mmm
and you're very comfortable in silence -
yeah and I've noticed is you'll you'll
like say something and give the audience
a chance to almost like breathe with you
and right then they like laugh like oh
here's the thing about that next
technique and then explain the technique
to it and that's great I mean I like how
you do that because some can interpret
that wrong something here oh you're
comfortable in silence like laughing no
how're you know that's what our the
thing about it is you've got to keep in
mind that these people are hearing these
jokes for the very first time so even
though you know how you felt and how it
goes you for me I give them the minute
to soak in the joke to feel it and
really laugh boom and now it's locked in
and then we move on to the next one and
instead of just speeding through cuz you
speed through people will miss things
and I think even like my hour special I
kind of accelerated just a little more
because I know that in television
there's rewatch value so if you miss
something or TV you go back and watch it
again which is extraordinary if you got
Amazon Prime find my special because
people are watching it twice yeah I got
like so many people like you I watched
it again today
and when I talk about the dream
like the dream I'm currently living the
dream in the dream is like dropping a
special like nationwide and like people
watching it you know and reaching out
and telling you what they liked about it
and my personal joy it's not one part
you know in that craft it really touches
the heartstrings cuz every time I get a
message it's like oh man I love that
think about Darrell or it's like oh man
I love the Heimlich maneuver yeah right
so I keep getting everyone's favorite
part is a different part and that that
really sticks out to me and I'm just
like I'm super grateful I'm thankful
that the opportunities that I got and I
was so happy that and I hope I continue
to just take advantage of every
opportunity that I was able to get
that's what's amazing about this moment
and you sang that I was like starting to
tear up a little bit because it's like
you've been doing this almost 20 years
you've had some successes here and
you've been working towards this moment
and you're like no one else will buy it
fine I'll self produce it and then now
it's like you you have this moment oh I
do have an Amazon special and it is
making an impact and we were just saying
off camera like it is trending right now
like people are gravitating literally
trending on Amazon Prime right now my
hours is so printing and I mean we do
this for so many you know different
reasons but I've always been a guy
that's wanted you know an hour special
and when I made it I was so happy my
first one and I'm still proud of it and
the second just to be offered a platform
and for people to see it like across the
country and different other countries oh
man that I mean like I'm not done by any
means or so in that part is why got in
it that was one of my main goals and
that goal is checked and now I just want
to make a bad one I feel like now I owe
the people something even funnier and
they love this but I'm like yo man I
gotta grow I gotta figure out what's the
but you're even big on mindset and you
do you like practice your award speeches
in the mirror less absolutely you're big
on this mindset and success being a
mindset yeah I felt it I've always I've
always seen amazing things for myself
you know but that that doesn't hurt that
people have been planting that in your
head for years like I'm kind of one of
those people that people see like okay I
don't know what it is but something
something's gonna happen something you
know and you know I'm not like blind to
that so that has helped you know and
believing in yourself is like the
biggest part of this and you know like
total so that that doesn't hurt the case
and especially with comedians we can we
can go through highs and lows and oh
yeah this is awesome and all of a sudden
the rug gets pulled out from underneath
you like where how how do you kind of
control your mental state throughout all
that I think I've lost emotion I really
think like I'm so even keel man like no
one really has seen me at some
incredible high and incredible low I'm
like literally this across the board and
I think putting in so many years and
entertainment me personally I'm just
jaded black up just like nothing it's
very few things that are even funny to
me you know like I'm just kind of I've
seen so much that even when I get the
call for the next yell you got casted
I'm like and they're all on the phone
all the managers and the agents and
they're looking for this big reaction
and I'm like yeah thank you because I'm
incredibly grateful but I just don't
have that energy anymore - just like
scream out the window I was like I've
seen a lot so I love this and I love
nothing more than like comedy but I've
just been in it and I haven't stopped
like I literally since I started
I haven't taken time off I'm just like
I'm doing this mm-hmm and there's no
like it feeling oh there's no
you know it's just go go just keep going
no excuses nothing but do you find
having goals helps that momentum keep
moving forward it's important to have
goals okay I think when you do make
goals for yourself what you do is you
mentally put that into the like
atmosphere you put it in the world and
then if you're focusing on it you'll
achieve it you know just leave it on
that list so you get bodies your mind
can see it and you'll just reach it so I
think it's incredibly incredibly
important to have goals but keep in mind
there's other things that are gonna come
to you that may not be on your goals
list and you jump on that you know maybe
you want to be on this is us only dream
but maybe that's not for you maybe you
end up on whatever the next show is
mm-hm and that's great just you know
keep yourself open oh you've had so many
opportunities how do you pick which ones
to say yes and which ones the same note
well I picked them all now cuz no one
knows me just do it all no not so much
there's a ton of crap that you just
turned down cuz you just like it doesn't
work it just doesn't work so what I'm
doing now like it's I'm getting great
auditions but my audition caliber has
went up because of this new special
right it's like buzz or something ever
since I did this NBC thing like last
year it kind of just put my face back
out there a little more and then with a
special that's just bringing in an
audience so I think that's helping my
audition caliber and I think that's
important but in the meantime I want to
act so I would take roles just so I can
get the you know the experience that it
takes to become good and then maybe
great it's not something you just jump
into and you just talented about it man
actors put in if not more time than
comedians to become great actors it's
not one of those things you just cuz you
do stand-up you're just great an actor
yeah we're like delusional in that sense
though we're like I can do anything and
then
it's just not the case man nothing
around talented acting and it's very
admire boy it's amazing to watch yeah I
remember you you've talking about like
being face to face with Ed Helms and
you're like he was like eight different
people you're like I need to get better
at acting so that was scary yes so yeah
just being in a room with someone who'd
like clicks great in the character I
hadn't seen that before
uh-huh so that was wasn't being around
keke palmer on said of the movie pimp
yeah I just watched her do methods when
there were emotional scenes to get
herself to a point I'm like yo this is
way bigger this is way bigger than like
people think it is it's not just going
out there and find the paper and doing
your lines it's investing into deep
feelings and just jumping in and
becoming whoever this character is and
that's that's who gets the award
nominations those actors hey which you
did you got an Emmy
yes nominee nomination nomination hey I
mean we're sorry you know yeah but it's
crazy cuz was for a dramatic role you
know and the thing about it it was like
a one take it like shot so it was
literally a 17 minute dramatic let me
tell you the energy it just took every
ounce of energy to to act a door to be
that so exhausting I was so beat and
then we would reshoot it and reshoot it
and after you did it like three times it
was like nothing left
it's nothing left but to look back and
say that I got an Emmy nomination I
guess to work it mattered but man it's
heavy very are you is acting kind of you
said you want do another special but is
acting like gonna become a big part of
your focus here's a name I want to I
want to act but again you get in where
you fit in right so man if comedies
calling which I feel like I want to do
that forever you know tour right jokes
you can do that
in my sleep I'm gonna continue to do
that but you know if the atman doors
open up and I get opportunities you know
then I'm gonna jump on him but stand-up
is like what gets me everything every
role of guy it was because like it was
connected to somehow someone knowing me
from stand-up so this is like it's the
it's the it's the sauce stand up is the
sauce yeah it gets me pretty much like
everything
well it's step man a TV show concept as
well hey man they can sleep on it if
they want but soon as I decide to so
produce it so amen
it's already written it's already
written it already character Lee broke
down I already got episodes and man now
that I just started I just started this
releasing all the actual home videos and
pictures of me and step man well people
are really seeing the visual and it's
it's it's something it's something and
when you say it's already written you
have like multiple episodes written or
you have like a I have I have like three
episodes written but they're not in
sequence I just wrote them all at
different times so they're just kind of
like non-connected different episodes
because I've been pitching this show for
like years
you know and I think everything comes
with a buzz man you gonna have the
dopest idea in the room but they give it
to you know to me I see more of the
people getting it other people that are
hot whoever's hot is getting that next
deal so that's what you got to do you
got to make yourself hot but TV is so
finicky and I've heard people they get
the show they taped the show and then
the show still doesn't come out like I'm
in every step of the way my problem with
Network uh-huh you know until they
change the format I'm not you know I'm
not so interested in network television
now I can do clean shows all day but I
would want to go where I'm gonna get a
guaranteed six or eight episodes out the
gate to you know give it a chance but I
don't even know why they canceled shows
anymore it's just one day I'm like what
happened - it was great show
it's just history you know it's just
gone so I would like an opportunity but
let me tell you where I'm at okay I'm in
a good working business with Amazon
Prime right now in Amazon is one of
those companies that are really looking
to grow right now I can tell ya and
they're putting on some amazing shows
man like I'm watching this show two boys
right now with these superheroes that
are corrupt one of the best shows out
right now okay no joke and it's cool to
just have a nice working relationship
with people who believe in you they gave
me my first nationally released special
and I'm very grateful about that well
you won the NBC stand-up competition yes
so you have a holding deal with NBC
I had it ran out oh yeah I made a nice
bit of money on that and I'm still I
still talk to them like regularly so
that's like cool we got a good working
relationship which is great that's what
this is about networking yeah you know
building trust and then putting out
quality content can you can you talk
more about the networking piece because
I feel like after you filmed Letterman
then you like got the office like not
long after they was really near than
that but it's funny how it works man
before my Letterman aired when everyone
knew I had let him in which I booked on
my own I had all these agency meetings
all these manager meetings people just
started coming out of like wherever you
know and everything's predicated on buzz
man when they someone feels like okay
this is about to be big they want to be
the first ones in you know so yes I got
the office right after Letterman cuz
that let him and just started throwing
me in clubs and I was working I was you
know I got great representation and so
that kept me busy then I got the office
and then you know auditioned a bunch got
a little something here in there and
then I felt like to a degree I fizzled a
bit you know I just kind of like hosted
and coasted and then I was like okay
like you gotta get back out
there even though I felt like I was
doing stuff I still personally felt like
yo man get talked about right you know
without being one of these weird ask
people to just say some my Klout [ __ ]
you know just to be you know seen a
heard you know so I've done a couple
like a movie hand and then that's why I
jumped on that NBC thing I'm like it'll
just hop in this and you know do it real
quick you know drop these jokes and so
yeah that went obviously that went
extremely well you know and it didn't
hurt it didn't hurt the case and then
next thing you know you know that was a
special knocking at the door and boom
did they just come through your agency
who Amazon like how cuz it's like your
shop your first self-produced you're
like shopping shopping shopping shopping
but did they like come to you yes yeah
they came rate rate today agent and they
were like we would love to work you know
with Mike and I was like I would love to
work with you and then BOOM you know we
recorded it was amazing night it was
over the course of two shows I shot the
first show that's a little worried oh
yeah cuz you know like it was a cool
amount of people but it was the energy
was liked you know and I kind of even
thought that for the second show that
the energy was even like but it was
better than the first show and I
performed and I was like I mean that
went cold but I don't think a special
can just be just cold you know and I was
and everyone reassuring they're like no
it was great
I'm like no no and so the second show
man I just it was do or die
it was just like whatever it takes like
drop go sell get in there work you know
and I just dipped in man and jumped in
and I'm all I can say is you don't know
how anything will be received but how
it's being received now is like man you
talk about tears you just see people
like you just seeing yourself come up
and post you're like oh man this is this
is never what I thought you know I just
thought of you you you
I hope one day I would get it special
but to see it being received on such a
level where you know they're talking
about you Ellis I can work more now
right it's like new confidence it's like
okay great now I'm gonna get work
because they know that like I got this
out and I can attract people I can tell
jokes so I can tell you I watched it
with my wife and she plays this coloring
app on her phone like all times you know
like we're watching TV and there are a
few jokes by your wife she like laughed
and then like she put her phone down and
like watched it like I can't tell you
how big of a five-star review that has
come to my wife her phone dude and I was
just like oh is she feeling okay like
yeah she was into it like it's it hits
it hits a universal note and it really
I'm trying to tell my story I'm telling
my story with with mine and watching
your specials and it's like okay this is
a way to do it where you're just kind of
telling your story and your personal
experience right it's it's personal but
it's like you're talking bout your
family and you're talk about your wife
and I think it's mysterious wife like
who is I googled her I was like who is
this lady I really think it really hits
were couples to my special really into a
couples I have so many this happens a
lot where like women will come to the
show and they'll come to me and they're
like I'm so mad my husband's not with me
to see this and that happens the most so
now like I think after people see the
special they will come together cuz it
in telling my story that's what I'm
talking about I'm talking about love I'm
talking about hate you know I'm talking
about an old-ass stepkid I'm talking
about like things you get from your
parents that you're not even proud of
you know it is a lot and I think that's
I'm twisting on my own personal
evolution what's been your wife's
reaction to like all this personal
material a man is it baby she'd been in
the game for so long with me that you
know we've been through the heart like
the real heart we've been through that
storm and I hope there's not any more
storms
you know but it started off really bad
she wasn't into the material a lot of my
material was like undeveloped so instead
of saying hateful stuff with a good
twist it was just hateful you know it
was just me expounding upon our
relationship without the tweek funny in
this so I get hot I wasn't easier for
her you know but in developing and
becoming a better creator or performer
or writer now she's all aboard because
this it's just not it's not like hurtful
like if you watch it you could see every
joke it comes from a place of life this
is a dude who's in love who's just
dealing with his own issues and trying
to try to make this work he just doesn't
know how to did did you break her down
or was there a moment where she was like
okay you're gonna do it regardless like
and I was incredibly selfish man okay I
was just like I'm doing this to the
point where you know things were like on
the ropes things were bad man but it's
this like the marriage yeah man it's
comedy especially early on it's an
addiction yes no it's kinda like that's
all I want to talk about so it
monopolized every conversation she's
like that's all you talk about that's
all I wanted to do I stopped working at
a certain point I used to had his job
where you could work 50 hours a week but
they called you in and I stopped taking
like the calls in to go to work because
I'm driving the organ for $50 you know
I'm like I'm doing this and you know it
was really tough in the house but now
where we are now even she looks back and
she's like yo those were bad times but I
see what you had to do to get us where
we are now like where she is now she's
literally putting new floors in our
house right now and that that is like
from comedy victory from freaking Karen
installing wood floors yo yo man and
here's me man like I ain't even in it
and this is the craziest thing to say
out loud but the money doesn't move me
it never has for I get that the family
needs to eat and it's only been about
her and the money in the cash like she
doesn't want me to be cheated out of
what I deserve for gigs but I just want
to do it and be a respected artist all I
care about
I just care about my talent being
respected you know and that's it she
could keep all the money she can have
all that man I'm like that's not what
I'm about how instrumental is she in the
actual comedy career cuz like my wife
personally I am more of like I just want
to be really great at comedy and just be
this artist my wife's like but it is a
job and like being married has kept me
motivated to find new avenues and new
ways you know yeah being a new
motivation how instrumental is she in
your career like that she's very
hands-on I mean she really protects me
man from holes you know and she like
it's just making sure that I stay away
from that world so she's really
interactive and all of that room she
makes sure I answer all emails she's
very happy she helps she's really smart
so I would I would call her pretty
hands-on now she's busy with the house
you know and and she gets caught up in
her stuff and so I end up having to do
you know a lot on my own or whatever but
as a whole man yeah yeah man that whole
theory of having like a strong woman
behind you is important it works for
some people I'm one of those people and
what resonated with me is you I heard
you say that a shift when your
relationship was when it became the
comedy was like our comedy instead of
just like yours absolutely and that's
what we call it in the house cuz that's
what it is okay this is ours this is our
success and that that did that changed
everything but it wasn't me just saying
it it was me believing it you know it's
really ours man we get to celebrate this
when we go on vacations this is because
of what we did
here yeah and she's a big part of it
even though I'm like you know I'm gonna
do writing the jokes and performing it
you know like a lot of my energy comes
from our interactions and I every
day-to-day stuff so hmm yeah so and in
landing this plane here the question and
that was great like there's so many just
parallels that it's it's very inspiring
the timing of this interview is amazing
great so what I always ask comedians is
like their epic boo or bombings story
like you we're talking about all the
success you're having but we're nowhere
without our failures and is there a
top-of-mind story of a show you did
where everything went wrong and it's
just an unforgettable man you know why
is it that that's what you remember the
most it's almost like when there's a
crowd of 500 people but there's one
person with their arms crawls not
laughing you remember that person oh you
know and I do man I mean there's this
I hate when comedians say they don't
bomb that hurt you I've had a few people
say that on here and I'm just like
really that's where we're gonna go with
this I think people don't know what
bombing is and I got so many different
you know definitions of bombing like one
in particular is like when you you're
afraid to take risk
so there's times when I'll have that new
joke in my pocket but I just wanna kill
this crowd instead of trying this new
piece that's gonna make me a better
performer so even though like they
laughed and they buckled over I bombed
because I had fear hmm I was acting like
a little [ __ ] no so that to me but what
we're really discussing right now I
think it was like 2006 and Stockton
California perfect how's that a fashion
show and I remember getting booked for
this because they had so many comedy
auditions and they were clowning
everybody else like at any one funny
bubble but I was like a heck of a me you
know of course I would an extra cocky
you know and this is a guy that at the
time is like three years then you know
are you gonna have to do is they're
gonna bring up axe you're gonna jump
five minutes I mean you're gonna do five
minutes in between while people change
clothes and then different acts perform
I was like a breeze you know and then
man I remember that day I go up and I
just jump right into material at a
fashion show instead of being a host no
one even knew I was a comedian and then
think about three years in the caliber
of content you were bringing to the
table so they're staring at me and I'm
like just bring up the next act you know
and I bring up the first act and then
they're like okay boom first acts goes
then I come out and they're like all
right five minutes just five minutes
while we get the next thing you know how
long five minutes is when you burn all
your material in the first three minutes
now I can feel everything rain and all
the bad everyone's staring at me like
they starting to like talk amongst each
other and then they like yo get on stage
man they start yelling this is a
Stockton is a pretty aggressive town and
they just like yelling now I started
getting in attack mode
but I only have one come back and I'm
like your mother
[Laughter]
they were like start with your mother
stop damn and I had nothing but I had to
stay on stage so then I'm just up there
with nothing to say sweating
uncomfortable people are born the lavash
and show people in between they sucked
too so it's like the performance is in
between was terrible was the worst show
oh yeah so I got I just got booed man
like out of Stockton it hurt and then I
was like I got hit with that why am i
doing this even though I wasn't a
conventional comedy show it's just like
know what you know what am i doing man
why do I need this know and those things
man you just never forget they just like
sit here somewhere NASCAR has really a
scart it's just bad they won't go away
no matter how much therapy you get
have you did you do therapy I have tried
it yeah
oh do the like just going yeah I think
it told us the interview is over
hold on then I guess back back and you
know I've I've had interviews on here
bomb and one of them was batteries dying
SD cards filling up so you know you just
got to prepare I mean I always be ready
miss elaboration you know I mean that's
what we learn in this business man you
got to be prepared for anything that
Mike might go out at the show you know
the lines my god anything can happen
yeah right so let's cleanse our palette
here at the end be guess your your
Letterman experience you actually got
bumped three times before you got to
actually perform but in those bumping 's
you actually met Steve Martin yeah
that's my favorite and I would love to
know what that experience was like yeah
I mean it's I guess I forgot that
anything can happen when you're in the
greenroom for the David Letterman Show
uh-huh it was weird I'm just in there's
some fruit you know and I'm just like
waiting to go on and then here comes
this guy and it's like Steve Martin just
stand in the doorway like you know and I
hey I had just finished reading this
book so it was like I read his book like
three months ago so on to me I'm like yo
is that one of them universe things when
you focused on something and it just
comes to like life you know and very
brief you know he was in the hallway and
I just told him I just read your book
and he was just kind right you know I
didn't had much to say he wasn't like we
were on the road together and he's like
alright this is everything of course
just like that brief interaction that
was like oh this is fun to watch this is
cool to see and I was incredibly
discouraged at that time because I think
that was like the second time I was
bumped from Letterman so then I was like
already semi defeated in the greenroom
and he pops up
and he's not why I got bumped it was
like some other group oh but it's one of
those serendipitous moments I guess yeah
it should she read his book and there he
is yeah right it's fun to watch man it's
just great to see like there's all types
of different successes and it's great to
see you know like this is a field yeah
so I always thought like yo man I can do
this this is I can do this and like live
a life and that's why I never wanted you
know like just anything basic I just had
to prepare myself to make sure that no
matter what happened with this I did
have other stuff I could well you got to
open for Russell Peters and to see
comedy at that scale that probably
opened up your mindset also right a man
that is a that's just too big that's
about like that's a one percenter
success left right like Russell Peters
successes like you when you open for him
you're in crowds of like 20,000 people
of different cultures that just are
happy to be there even though they spent
like $60 a ticket it's like okay that's
just comedy that's just like you getting
too much sometimes I was that was so
great to have that receptive crowd at
such a young time in my career you know
and he's I've heard he's like one of the
nicest guys I've heard him violet he's
bought like computers for comics he's
like had people stay at his house for
free when he's not there like he is very
generous yeah I'm a very great comic and
his brother used to manage me and we
just yeah cool relationship still still
great dude man and just like everyone
man he's just working to you know create
the next big thing as well so in in
closing here do you have any closing
advice for comedians out there any oh
absolutely man like I think the whole
thing is like stop talking about it you
know just not talking about it and like
do the work you cannot cheat the process
and you've learned that man I learned
that when I don't record and listen to
it every day or every week you know
not cheat the process of candy and when
stuffs not happening it could be it
could be because you're not putting in
the work you you want to reach the level
that you want to get to this is a prime
example putting in the work it pays off
so please let them know where they can
support you checking out the special let
them know everything yeah Amazon Prime
the title of the special is step man you
go to my website my step man calm last
night I said big-ass teeth calm I own
all the domain name go to all of them
all to Instagram and Facebook and
Twitter all that stuff it's to ease in
the middle so it's Mike II win feel they
can find it on that and they should they
should come out and say where they saw
me too
so we know that you know they saw it on
this show
yeah or heard it on this show yeah I
always encourage people that watch or
listen reach out to my guests and reach
out to Mikey Winfield and let him know
you heard him on here and that his time
was very well spent
yeah and may is interesting like it's
again people are watching this special
and they're enjoying it and it's not no
of course it's not like every person you
know it's negative reviews too but
that's part of it I'm even happy to get
the negative review yeah it's pretty
cool how do you feel about this show how
do you feel about being on here oh man
this is a terrible experience man and no
no no man is yeah obviously it's great
it's great
well would you mind closing out looking
into the camera let him know who you are
and why they should listen to hot breath
oh hey this is Mikey Winfield and guess
what you don't have nothing else to do I
like their paws hustling it's now really
would you go are you okay there's no
what you're gonna say okay that's great
no ma'am obviously hang out listen to
some different comedy perspective and if
you can take one thing from this you've
won that's it
Mikey Winfield thanks be on hot breath
my man writes on everything
who knew we did it we did it we closed
we made it
[Music]
I breath